I'm just fascinated by the loose
emissions I just think they're the most
amazing things they are as close to a
miracle as I ever hope to get I mean
where is that stuff coming from you know
the on a good mushroom rush in 45 or 50
minutes I have the impression that I see
more art than the human species has
created in the last 12,000 years and
clear does this stuff come from
if I could capture a single 30 second
bursts I could be Peter max you solder
and saw that there are Dali Pablo
Picasso and all the rest enrolled into
one because the amount of creative
imagery is staggering and as artists I
think this is what we should all be
challenged by I would like graphic
artists to go in there these are the
people we need to send you know these
are the people with the unique talents
that can serve the rest of us we can't
send instruments with cameras the way we
live to Mars or the moons of Jupiter no
we have to send artists artists
preferably with the death of memory
we can take snapshots that come back and
with airbrush oil and computer render
these things we need to try and create a
grammar of hallucinogenics as' probably
in a computer environment we need to try
and understand what the laws are in the
ruling these visual transforms because
this this is an endless font of images
for design and God forbid fashion
advertising the whole thing
I mean clearly we are driving images out
of the unconscious but I dare say if we
could if we could access the psychedelic
unconscious they would do few movies
around but look like this this is a rule
created out of the assumptions of linear
print culture and BA house economics but
there are other
to to do it and that's what the Hollis
antigens makes so explicit